zwei wochen groko die flitterwochen sind
vorüber mal gucken wie die stimmung hier
im bundestag ist wie ist denn die
stimmung hier im bundestag
so war glaube ich nicht von welcher
partei sind sie denn von der spd von der
spd und zufrieden gerade hier haben wir
sind zufrieden mit der gruppe
es läuft super ja ehrlich ja wunderbar
war warum was super macht spaß zu
regieren zu gestalten ja und wann fängt
das anders gestalten und deswegen dabei
es geht um das thema groko das heißt ich
hab ich gar keine frage an sie ich
wollte einfach mal hallo sagen
vervollständigen sie den satz das ist
eine frage die spd verhält sich zur cdu
wie ein käfer auf dem rücken zur wie ein
käfer auf dem rücken zu einem fallenden
platt weil das das blatt auf den käfer
fällt wird umgedreht
der kern des reaktors plattform eine
symbiose der käfer feldes tod nicht
unbedingt kabel war aber halb tot die
beine fehlen es erledigt er ist so gut
wie käfer von dem blatt oder affen blatt
fällt der verlage nicht die beine
sondern krabbelt immer weiterkommen ob
es verletzte kefer keinen verletzt sein
kann aber auch weiter machen jetzt setzt
die union ja verstärkt auf real rechten
populismus tut ihnen die spd nicht
manchmal auch ein bisschen leid dass sie
die so verarscht haben ich sehe keinen
rechten populismus nachricht nicht
kennst du weißt aber was seehofer so
raus haut ist schon so islam nicht zu
deutschland so sind ja schon sage ich
mal könnte auch von der optik kommen ist
nichts neues
der afg zumindest nicht diese engstelle
hatten wir schon immer
also rechter populismus findet bei uns
generell nicht statt
oder eben immer wie zufrieden sind sie
mit der groko läuft es unterirdisch oder
überirdisch schlecht dass und aber
richtig eine gute richtung
das läuft gut das heißt welche partei
sind die cdu den ja bis jetzt gut das
center kann man lachen lachen wir doch
mal zusammen über die spd sympathisch
ich muss jetzt nur besuchergruppe
deswegen kann ich leider nicht zur
verfügung
die ist wichtiger als ich ich muss
dorthin ich habe die pflicht übernommen
juli an welcher partei er steht dann
können sie weitergehen
zwei wochen groko also die stimmung ist
frost sich entnervt und resigniert also
viel besser als ich gedacht habe und
damit zurück nach köln
[Applaus]